it is time for this week's pet project
laurie herron joins us from the nspca
actually
she's from somewhere else today and
she's adopting out frank mourinho and i
think that's
wonderful that it's about time we found
him a home i think this is a good thing
that's right ted well frank marino needs
a home because
he certainly um doesn't have much of a
home to live in here of course i'm
i'm joking because we are at frank's
fabulous home this morning to talk about
the fabulous promotion that frank is um
doing with nevada spca
to help animals like ella here even find
more
loving homes um frank is giving a pair
of tickets to legends in concert
to everyone that everyone that adopts an
animal from nevada spca
in july and august well frank's show has
been around for so long
he is legend in this town uh not only
for show but also for helping out in the
community like he's doing here
i don't know if he can hear us but
frankie if you can uh why
is this important to you well
you know right now i'm starring in the
legends and concert show at the
tropicana
and i used to do work with them with uh
divas but
legends was so nice to say we'll give a
pair of tickets out to everybody that
purchases
a don't would not purchase adopts a dog
during the summer months and i was like
great and then we teamed up with lori
and
all these beautiful dogs i'm meeting i'm
learning so much and they're just so
cute i want every one of them i just
don't have the room
i know right and lori who do you have
with you today besides frank
so kendall this is sweet ella ella
is a ten-year-old pit mix um you know
kendall
our slogan at nevada spca is to find
happiness both for
our pets and for the people that adopt
them and ella really is someone that
deserves to find happiness we
transferred her in from another shelter
where she'd been there for too long over
a month and she was in i guess a really
dark
um kennel and not getting a lot of
attention
she is very sweet and calm she
would do better by herself to be an only
dog
and probably with older children um
she we do recommend a special diet just
to help her with some skin irritation
um but she is very sweet will be very
loving you can see that she's laying on
the couch here with frank and me and
loving it she'll be a great lap dog if
you need a companion to watch television
so really hope that somebody is watching
today kendall that
wants to give sweet ella home and of
course they're going to get that pair of
fabulous tickets to legends and concerts
i love it and it's
such a great cause frank this is near
dear to your heart right
she might not be available if i keep
playing with her like this oh my god
and i gotta tell you people i know a lot
of locals legends the longest running
show in las vegas
a lot of locals have seen it already but
that is a show you could come back to
time and time again because it's always
changing right now we have rod stewart
tina turner elvis
but it's constantly changing that next
season is going to be i believe it's
british invasion and all the british
stars maybe
george michael's elton john you know so
you never know who's gonna
show up but a lot of fun and it's
something to do finally we could get out
of the house so locals can get out
the reasonably priced show and
people who are adopting are going to be
doing a good deed
as well 100 agreement it is an
entertaining show what a great cause so
thank you frank
thank you lori if you're interested in
adopting a pet you can call that phone
number or go to the nevada spca website